Brad, due to the Connor Spinnick membership, welcome going into surgery tomorrow is the advanced healing program the best for surgery recovery.
So I think you're talking about the right programs. I do have, we have a dog blog post on surgery.
You might want to look at that because there are some specific right programs you might want to follow after surgery. Also after watching the right tutorial and frequently asked question videos, the information is a little conflicting you say you want people to snuggle with the hammerball.
0 to 18 inches away from them in bed. Jason, I think you mean Jake at state for Jake at Turing.
It's Jake with true rife says that the Jack hammer amplifier, the effect of the hammerball is magnified 256 times and it can be placed under the bed.
I would prefer that under the bed approach since I'm a light sleeper, but I have a sizable tumor with lung metastasis, your recommendation.
So understand many, many of the videos that I have made over the years was prior to true rife coming out with the Jack hammer amplifier. This is a new piece of equipment as a last summer.
So prior to the Jack hammer amplifier, I told everybody you should just snuggle with your right ball. You need to snuggle with the ball.
So personally, I don't use the Jack hammer. I just snuggle with my right and I snuggle with my right every night. It just stays on my stomach every night.
And most people in this call probably in that same situation, you know, we didn't start including the Jack hammer tell just last year when it came out.
I don't have the Jack hammer. Most of my patients don't have this piece. Do you need it? No, however, if you want to sleep with the ball under the bed, then you need it.
So if you have it, you can sleep with it under your bed. You put it under your bed. So that is the conflicting information.
Well, it's only conflicting because you're using another piece of equipment. So if you add the Jack hammer to your ball, then you could put them all under the bed. You don't have to sleep with snuggle with it.
And that will solve your problem. So yes, that's exactly what you can do.